here's an article from for Forbes why
gold is a good investment right now may
be set for a new record price gold
prices are approaching at their all-time
high with a 10 increase this year driven
by investors seeking a safe haven asset
amid economic uncertainty UBS predicts
gold could surpass its record price
setting a target of 2200 per ounce by
next march citing factors such as
weakening US dollar banking sector
stress debt ceiling concerns easing
interest rate expectations and the
likelihood of a recession gold price
surge is primarily influenced by macro
variables rather than supply and demand
fundamentals UBS analysts cleave a
ruckard notes that goals price is driven
by factors like U.S real estate and the
strength of the US dollar the surgeon
gold price is unique as it is unrelated
to its case so use case what do you
think is going to be happening with gold
well uh I think it's a question of
timing right so if you say is it five
years or is it next five months I'll go
ahead and start by saying that I think
everyone should own gold and I don't
really see it as an investment I just
see it as insurance so regardless of the
price I always put it 10 of my portfolio
because I don't care if the price goes
up or down it's just purchasing power
it's it's that insurance policy now if
you say the next five months I would say
my base case is that gold actually goes
down believe it or not because I think
that's overbought and if you look at
history going back to cover to the GFC
when you have a crisis situation gold
actually goes down because it's the only
thing on the balance sheet that these
big funds can sell it's the only thing
that has a bid because it's doing its
job right so if you go back to Lehman
Brothers you see that gold just crashes
and then once rates get down to zero and
the market says okay we we've we've
kicked the can down the road as Pat was
saying because we did all this we'll
call it quote unquote money printing
then they gold rips higher absolutely
rips higher and it did the exact same
thing during covid so if you say the
next five months I'd say there's a my
base case is that gold actually trades
lower but if you say over the next three
years or the next five years I think it
goes way way way way higher but I don't
know in real terms definitely in nominal
terms but I again that's what the caveat
of I think anyone should always own gold
pretty much at any price because it's
not an investment it's insurance I think
I agree with you 100 I didn't really
care about the next five months because
that's not an investment Horizon for me
yeah but I think in the long term gold
certainly does continue to go up
um because of exactly what we said we're
de-dollarizing because we've got nothing
to do because we're detolarizing we've
got nothing else to delilize in right
now there's only one other neutral
Network which is not owned by any of the
players right and that neutral network
is gold right like if you think about
currencies currencies are all linked to
a specific Country Gold is not
necessarily linked to a specific country
right it's the second Network now the
law of network effect says that it's
it's called barabasi's law and I can I
can maybe break down Network effects but
the law of network effects states that a
in the absence of regulatory
interference users will flock to the
busiest nodes
so what's the busiest note the busiest
node is the US dollar today
so let's just think about what network
effects actually are
if
a network is defined as anything where
each individual user increases the value
of the network exponentially okay so
let's just quickly Define that
if we talk about WhatsApp which is a
telecommunications network if there are
two people on the network myself and
Adam the maximum number of calls I can
make on the network is I can call you
and you can call me two people can make
all this two calls in anything
if we add Patrick to the network I can
call you you can call me I can call
Patrick he can call me and he Patrick
can call you and you can call Patrick so
now there's six there's six so we've
increased the value of the network
exponentially one person exponentially
so the first thing is that networks
continue to grow at an accelerating rate
exponentially which is the most powerful
effect in the world that's why that's
why networks are so powerful that's why
Google is so powerful and Amazon's so
powerful and Uber's so powerful is
because they are all networks that's the
only thing that they all have in common
that that is amazing now the second rule
of networks is in in the absence of any
regulatory interference users will flock
to the busiest node so always say if
you're Landing in a new country and
you've got to decide whether you're
going to go into WhatsApp or some other
chat messenger you're gonna go to
Whatsapp because everybody's using
Whatsapp that's the busiest network node
so it's the same thing with with money
because money is the ultimate Network
the US dollar is the network with the
most users and therefore people will
flock that Network
the second biggest Network
is gold
and so you have to hold you have to hold
gold because of the network effect that
it has in in the mandatory system and
that's why I agree with you I don't have
10 because I think each individual based
on their risk tolerance might be
slightly different but you have to hold
gold as part of your portfolio not to me
I see an extension of gold which is
digital gold and to me that's Bitcoin
and so I take some of that allocation
and put that some of that allocation
into Bitcoin yeah I was in Turkey a
couple months ago and uh I wanted to
spend we all know that they've gone
through this hyperinflation so I spent a
few days there I had a tour guide this
gal was probably 30 years old and I was
obviously asking yes
I like it
okay but uh my wife should only find out
I have a tour guide here in Miami yeah
all right just don't tell her it's an
end yeah so this weekend I was in South
Beach hanging out a couple tour guides
uh down there anyway go ahead George but
I was very inquisitive with pretty much
everyone I met you know I said how are
you guys dealing with this inflation and
they're actually dealing with it very
well but here was this was their
strategy what they do is they get paid
in Lira at the end of the week they pay
all their bills and anything they have
left over they immediately turn it into
dollars or gold yeah exactly what he was
saying then I went through the airport
that brand new airport they have that's
gorgeous and on my way out I just
happened to get a coffee you know out
and they opened the cash register I just
happened to look in that cash register
in turkey and all they had in there were
US Dollars well let me tell you what
happens when when you can't get US
dollars because the the flood happens
first of all they use US dollars but
then the problem is that everybody buys
up all the US Dollars and there's not
enough US Dollars and then you know what
they do that's the short squeeze I'm
talking well no they start using airtime
data in minutes so instead in South
Africa for example because we're in
Zimbabwe where you can't get dollars
what you trade in is you trade in
minutes of air time so call minutes or
gigs of data they do that in Ecuador as
well but I want to be very clear for the
viewers and I think you might might Echo
these thoughts I'm saying that the
dollar if we have a big crisis situation
you know does that flight to safety and
the liquidity issues we talk about the
dollar goes up but I'm talking about
going up against other Fiat currencies I
am not talking about the dollar going up
against goods and services in the United
States and this is a hard concept for
people to understand they have to look
at the dollar dollars two separate
currencies so inside the United States
we can have ten percent inflation
while the dollar is going up by 10
percent outside of the United States
relative to other Fiat currencies such
as the Euro the Turkish lira Etc and
people really need to understand that
concept so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]